sí
[Música]
la renuncia del presidente de geely
lanka gotabaya rajapaksa no pone punto
final a la crisis política y económica
que tiene a esa nación insular asiática
sumida en el caos con una población
completamente hernández y da con una
inflación fuera de control escasez de
productos básicos y una gigantesca deuda
externa la salida del poder del
mandatario y un eventual cambio de
gobierno si es que el parlamento logra
un consenso no terminara con la crisis
lo que sigue para civil blanca es un
largo camino hacia su recuperación pero
dónde queda y vemos algunos datos
básicos para conocer un poco más este
país asiático les doy algunos datos de
esta nación asiática este territorio es
una isla antiguamente era conocida como
ceylan y fue colonia británica hasta
1948 tiene una población de alrededor de
22 millones de habitantes y su capital
es la ciudad de colombo que es el punto
donde se ha concentrado la mayoría de
las manifestaciones ciudadanas su
economía durante muchos años se basó en
la producción agrícola algunos productos
como la canela caucho y el té de ceylan
son reconocidos por su buena calidad
alrededor del mundo entero pero años
después también su economía vivió una
industrialización y también la industria
del turismo empezó a jugar un papel
importante en su economía que ha pasado
entonces con este país para llegar a
este escenario vamos a ampliar esta
información con las invitadas que
tenemos para el programa de hoy pero les
doy algunos factores básicos porque son
muchos por ejemplo la inflación la alta
deuda externa la disminución de las
reservas internacionales corrupción a
nivel político déficit fiscal y la
crisis de la pandemia kobe 19 que fue ya
la estocada final para acabar con la
economía decir blanca entre otros
múltiples aspectos entonces así las
cosas que salida tiene entonces este
país qué figura política hay en sí de la
ncaa sea lo suficientemente destacada
para poder liderar a esta nación hacia
una recuperación económica que genere
confianza en los mercados pero sobre
todo confianza entre los ciudadanos
atención a tres países que juegan un
papel muy importante en cuanto a la
influencia que hay en sidi lanka estamos
hablando de india que es una gran
potencia regional china que es digámoslo
la potencia continental con la que siri
lanka tiene una larga completa y
endeudada historia y también un país
europeo el reino unido como antiguo
poder colonial que qué papel para jugar
entonces en la recuperación de este país
por eso hoy en el debate de france 24
sigue blanca la tormenta perfecta y para
eso hemos invitado para analizar este
tema a sabrina oliveira olivera ella es
magíster y doctorado en relaciones
internacionales también es especialista
en temas de la región de asia-pacífico
se encuentra en la ciudad de buenos
aires en argentina desde la ciudad de
bogotá se conecta soraya caro vargas
ella es doctora en ciencias políticas de
la universidad indira gandhi national
institute de nueva delhi y es directora
del centro de estudios sobre india
contemporánea y asia meridional de la
universidad externado que está ubicada
en la ciudad de bogotá en colombia
es el recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de toda esta conversación y este
debate pueden hacer todas sus preguntas
y comentarios a través de las redes
sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram en
facebook allí no se encuentran como roa
france24 bajo ese arroba santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 para que dejen
todos los comentarios también en youtube
pueden ver nuestra señal en streaming y
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que nos están escuchando a través de
nuestro podcast los invito a todos para
que también escuchen los contenidos de
nuestro programa que está disponible en
app el podcast en spotify en dice y en
tuning
pues muy bien comenzamos entonces el
análisis de este país asiático muy
lejano a la realidad de américa latina
pero que puede darnos indicios de esta
crisis económica a nivel mundial que
también puede golpear a algunas naciones
de nuestro continente comienza entonces
con sabrina olivera en la ciudad de
buenos aires- dándole la bienvenida del
programa sabrina gracias por estar con
nosotros y punto de partida la primera
pregunta para conocer posiciones de los
invitados como definiría entonces usted
esta tormenta perfecta en sidi la ncaa
cuáles fueron esos componentes
qué tal santiago bueno muchísimas
gracias por tenerme en cuenta para este
análisis y por supuesto también es un
gusto para mí compartir con soraya este
este debate a ver a mí me parece que hay
dos elementos fundamentales en el
estallido de este conflicto 11 de la
ncaa por un lado el punto de vista
económico y por el otro lado del punto
de vista político y porque digo el punto
de vista económico hay dos aristas que
me parece que son fundamentales también
respecto esto primero tiene que ver con
el turismo porque porque la pandemia ha
golpeado mucho a la región de aceh del
sur donde se encuentras blanca de hecho
es uno de los sectores económicos de
esos países que más afectados se vieron
por lo tanto el ingreso de divisas desde
esa perspectiva se ve restringido
además
activas algunos años en el 2019 en la
semana santa una serie de atentados
también en sede la ncaa y esto hizo por
supuesto que es cierto el sector del
turismo tuviera cierta reticencia de
viajar al ser y la ncaa afectando
nuevamente entonces a este sector tan
importante para un isla que es
paradisíaca en tiene playas realmente
muy lindas y también esto afecta a lo
que vendría a ser las remesas que es una
fuente importante también de ese país
asimismo desde el año pasado se ha
tomado una decisión una decisión un poco
crítica sobre todo porque se considera
que fue inconsulta respecto del sector
agropecuario de sri lanka y que tenía
que ver con la restricción en la
importación de ciertos fertilizantes y
esto obedecía a una intención de virar
hacia una economía verde una economía
orgánica por supuesto que esto no pudo
ser mantenido mucho en el tiempo de
hecho se mantuvo sólo algunos meses pero
en esos meses realmente hizo estragos
porque porque un país que dependen mucho
de su agricultura lo que termina
derivando toda esta situación es que las
cosechas las siembras y sobre todo las
personas que dependen del sector
agropecuario y todos los otros sectores
vinculados a ella se vieron
absolutamente afectados entonces esto
impacta en una escasez por supuesto de
alimentos
aumentan los costos porque obviamente
hay mucha más oferta y hay menos y hay
mucha más demanda pero hay menos oferta
si todo esto genera una devaluación digo
hay todo un proceso económico detrás de
y digo la otra arista que para mí era
muy importante analizar y que tiene que
ver también a mí me parece que es
fundamental en esto porque no solamente
es lo económico sino le debe al hartazgo
de los dylan que cesc con la familia
rajapaksa una familia que decía hace
muchísimos años forma parte del poder
que esto viene también incluso del padre
de los rajapaksa que hoy hoy vemos de
igual no solamente región pacta
presidente que está renunciando en estas
horas sino también el primer vicioso
tropiezo hermano que renunció hace
algunos meses entonces creo que esta es
la expresión de todo este cúmulo de
situación sí como titulamos el programa
una tormenta perfecta vamos a conocer el
punto de vista de soraya ya hemos puesto
sobre la mesa soraya algunos de los
puntos básicos ya vamos a profundizar en
ellos durante el análisis pero desde su
punto de vista que llevó a este país a
prácticamente irse por el abismo porque
el país está prácticamente en bancarrota
en términos económicos y con una
ausencia de liderazgo a nivel político
que no lo habían visto los ciudadanos y
dylan que cesc en los últimos años ni
siquiera en la época más difícil después
de la independencia durante la guerra
civil
como tú dices entralgo es la primera vez
que desde sus dependencias se relaja se
encuentra en una situación tan crítica y
difícil y yo creo que un elemento
adicional y muy importante sumada a los
que ha planteado
sabrina es la composición de la deuda el
destino en el cambio del perfil de la
deuda externa del país en el año 2004
como el banco mundial decide catalogar
acción blanca como un país de renta
media el origen de la deuda externa
estaban los multilaterales
tradicionales en el banco mundial en el
banco asiático para el desarrollo en
algunas culturas
de cooperación japonesas que prestaban
al 1% y con periodos de pago de 25 a 40
años hoy el perfil del lado de es
totalmente distinto del 47% de la deuda
está en manos de la banca comercial con
unas tasas del 6% o más y con unos
periodos de pago de 5 a 10 años lo que
le hizo muy difícil hacer banca manera
tal
a lo anterior se suma que en la
composición de esa deuda está china
involucrada de una manera muy fuerte un
13 por ciento está en manos del banco
asiático para el desarrollo en donde
todos sabemos que china ejerce una
influencia fuerte es un socio importante
el 10 por ciento directamente le
pertenece a china y en el 47 por ciento
del que hablaba en euros está la banca
comercial por supuesto hay una fuerte
incidencia de ese país en materia
crediticia por lo menos 235 proyectos
financiado de diferentes formas china en
firma en nuestro país vecino y maldivas
y cuánto es intereses claramente
estrategia si él
esos son otros vectores
importantes en
muchos puntos para analizar continúo con
soraya para hacerla la ronda a la
inversa hablemos de los problemas a
nivel internacional que le puede traer a
este país no poder pagar sus compromisos
internacionales que ya usted nos nos
puso acá al tanto sobre los porcentajes
que involucran a china a la banca
internacional y ya ya esa deuda que
tiene con otros bancos a niveles
comerciales sin duda alguna el
presidente o la persona que llegue a
liderar el país a partir de
este momento tendrá que negociar con
organismos internacionales para tener
acceso a créditos que van a endeudar más
al país
qué consecuencias puede traer entonces
para esta nación con una economía que
básicamente se enfocaba era en el
abastecimiento interno y tenía muy poca
exportación
efectivamente como no tienen fuentes de
pago de la deuda y ellos necesariamente
sir lanka necesariamente tiene que
lograr
acordar un rescate
ellos están negociando con dos frutos
uno tradicional son el fondo monetario
internacional con quien no quiso
negociar durante muchos años y el
presidente saliente o las líderes
salientes convocaron a los países
asiáticos a india china rusia japón a
crear una mesa crediticia paralela o
alterna que fuera menos costosa y que
implicará menos sacrificio para la
población teniendo en cuenta que pues
obviamente el fondo monetario
internacional va a seguir unas
contrapartidas bastante fuertes que
además se utilizan
responsabilidades en materia de derechos
humanos para quienes hicieron parte de
la violación de sus derechos durante la
guerra y ex sobre todo en las etapas
finales de la guerra
entonces en el de los efectos van a ser
muy duros para la población pero tienen
que lograr esa esas negociaciones con
ambos con ambos sectores por eso muchas
personas piensan que ya la crisis
terminó por eso empezará el programa si
la crisis con la renuncia del presidente
lo que le viene ahora al país para su
recuperación económica y social es muy
difícil y es muy paradójico ver un país
de renta media que venía con un
crecimiento bastante destacado para la
zona del sudeste asiático comparado con
otros países cercanos y verlo caerse así
en el abismo en términos económicos
sabrina regresó con usted en la ciudad
de buenos aires- mencionaba yo tres
países muy puntuales que tienen aquí un
papel importante destacado quiero que
con con soraya
veamos como es el papel que van a tener
cada uno de ellos en esta crisis cómo
pueden involucrarse y qué tanto están
involucrados en esta crisis comienzo por
india que es la potencias regionales el
país vecino es el país más cercano y
ejerce una gran influencia en términos
culturales en cercanías lingüísticas
culturalmente son bastante parecidos en
muchas cosas y pues hay mucha influencia
de línea qué papel puede jugar allí este
país en esta crisis y en salir de la
crisis
es bueno limpia es el hegemón de hacer
el surf y como vos bien decías tiene una
serie de lazos con celis lanka los
cuales no puedes conocer y además a
línea le interesa también aparecer
porque es india no aparece para ofrecer
de algún modo ciertas soluciones o
extender algunas manos hace de la ncaa
quien lo va a hacer o por lo menos eso
se avisora es precisamente china de
todos modos ignia desde que esta crisis
se vino suscitando ofreció líneas de
crédito también envió alimentos y sobre
todo envió medicamentos porque también
es un elemento que estaba escaseando en
ser y blanca y recordemos que india es
un país potencia la fabricación de
genéricos por lo cual desde ese punto de
vista hay miel interesa y por otra parte
también me gustaría mencionar no sé si
va a tener un papel tan relevante porque
en realidad es una asociación que está
bastante vamos a decir dormida en algún
modo pero es la shark la asociación
regional para la cooperación de asia del
sur en realidad si bien es un foro de
muy buenas voluntades y que no se pueden
así y abordar temáticas que tengan que
ver con conflictos internos por ejemplo
los conflictos entre india pakistán en
ese marco no se discuten pero sí es
cierto que podría llegar a darse digo es
una buena herramienta un buen ámbito
para empezar a discutir la cooperación
y la ayuda hacia este país que está en
esta situación tan dramática claro ahora
ya su opinión sobre la influencia de
india qué más puede hacer este país allí
en la región
pues en la influencia india es
importante pero está muy condicionada
como ustedes saben pues la de la
confrontación o las rencillas que
existen entre india y blanca pues han
sido evidentes durante las últimas
recetas particularmente por el
cuestionamiento de los irlandeses a la
financiación de la guerrilla también
desde el poder subcontinente de lindos
pases de india
hay cierta prevención de los tanques de
frente en sainthia y eso lo llevó a una
cercanía
persistente con china entonces eso ha
generado
desconfianza entre los dos países hay
empresas por ejemplo en este momento
indias de grandes conglomerados como el
grupo de los albano intentando invertir
en la banca pero están muy cautelosos
pues de las reacciones que pueda tener
el próximo gobierno en relación con las
inversiones indias porque si claramente
ha habido pues la preferencia de materia
de condiciones y seguridad es una
inversión china en el país pero
claramente para enviar inyectó
acostumbraba a cooperar y a liderar este
es starter se hablaba
es reciente es decir tx hablaba
recientemente pues sí está apoyando
económicamente en algunas instancias del
país
ahora ya continúo con usted
preguntándole por el papel de china esto
también puede ser un escenario donde
india y china se enfrenten un poco más
de frente por la influencia en este país
y la
quiero detalles de esa relación difícil
que tienen con beijing porque es un país
que ya está muy endeudado con china tuvo
que cederle un enorme puerto que
construyó en el sur de la isla conecte
el psib y blanca no tuvo con qué pagar
entonces le tuvo que dar un alquiler por
99 años al gobierno chino para su
explotación y pues básicamente no tiene
recursos para pagar todas estas deudas
que tienen y hay muchos proyectos que
estaban en pleno desarrollo en términos
de infraestructura
pues yo creo que primero tenemos que
aclarar cuál es el interés de china en
ser blanca se lanza es un punto
estratégico en el índico en el índico
porque por el índico se transan todos
los bienes que van de china a occidente
y de occidente a china y particularmente
las materias primas y el petróleo y
demás entonces cuidar esa esa ruta
comercial para china es muy importante y
por eso ha querido invertir y tener una
presencia bastante clara en esa en esa
parte del índico pero también es una es
una situación estratégica es una
localización estratégica en materia de
seguridad porque muy cerca están
apostadas también bases militares de
diferentes países de occidente e indique
y china quiere tener pues una presencia
clara en el país en esta zona lo cual
logró por ejemplo con los puertos de
gavardo está
colombo después de sus grandes
inversiones y de las difíciles
condiciones de pago que impulsó a los
estanques es en estas dos dos
megaproyectos
además china ha buscado ese
posicionamiento tratando de contener
precisamente a india y como lo decía
sabrina su posición hegemónica en el sur
de asia
pues en los últimos años lo que ha hecho
china es una política de forma de
diplomacia pública muy fuerte que ha
sido relativamente exitosa buscando es
disminuir las prevenciones frente a sus
inversiones
evitar los votos negativos en naciones
unidas por ejemplo de parte de ser
blanca y de partida activa
es un punto estratégico muy importante
para china en este momento china net no
ha manifestado su intención de
reestructurar la nueva la deuda
nuevamente o de generar nuevos fondos de
ayuda en distintos alústiza se haya
comprometido si también llama mucho la
atención el silencio de beijing en toda
esta crisis se han quedado callados y
han sido muy cautelosos sabrina su
opinión sobre este papel que tiene china
y este modo de diplomacia que no es el
único país en donde se han metido con
toda la el dinero de beijing para poder
hacer infraestructuras a cambio de
posiciones estratégicas y no es el único
país que está sumamente endeudado
también en el sur de europa hemos visto
algo parecido con montenegro con la
financiación de una superautopista que
construyó el gobierno chino o las
inversiones chinas y montenegro no ha
tenido como pagarla
bueno la verdad es que ahora ya lo ha
mencionado muy bien todo el interés que
tiene china en términos políticos en
términos estratégicos en términos de
seguridad y yo agrego a esta situación y
es en realidad la estrecha relación que
tenía china con la familia del rock page
a pacsa en efecto digamos todo esto de
los puertos del sur de sri lanka en
realidad tuvieron que ver de algún modo
con la financiación de la campaña de los
rajapaksa de hecho había informes que
eran bastante contraproducentes respecto
de ese puerto y sin embargo se continuó
con este proyecto de infraestructura y
entiendo de algún modo que el silencio
de beijing hoy eres a esta razón obedece
a que está esperando a ver quién es que
asume la presidencia
y además quien asume también como primer
ministro porque todavía la sensación de
que también el primer ministro el
ministro actual lo va a renunciar
entonces creo que están esperando desde
china a ver cuál va a ser el próximo
movimiento del tri lanka porque
realmente tranca hoy es un país que está
prácticamente de rodillas
y que va a tener que reestructurar
absolutamente todas sus deudas y habrá
que ver de qué manera conforman un nuevo
gobierno que represente todos los
intereses o por lo menos la mayoría de
los sectores involucrados
ahora también pero digamos que acción de
tiene respecto de china no se ha querido
igualmente que no tiene mucho margen de
maniobra no hay mucho margen de maniobra
sabrina continuó con usted preguntándole
muy puntualmente y rápidamente por el
papel que pueda tener el reino unido si
en algún punto como antigua potencia
colonial allí que fue pues el país que
gobernó esta isla a la isla de ceilán
hasta 1948 y tiene algún juego allí en
esta en esta ecuación del rescate que
pueda recibir es y blanca
a ver a mí me parece que por el momento
esto se está resolviendo desde el punto
de vista asiático
desconozco realmente si reino unido ha
expresado se ha manifestado al respecto
pero lo que yo creo es que hoy se dylan
acá está digo está viendo cuál es su
posición respecto del fondo monetario
internacional también o a lo sumo mira
qué hace china no la verdad es que
desconozco si reino unido está
ofreciendo algún tipo de ayuda la verdad
que no no lo he visto de todos modos
creo que esto también da cuenta un poco
de la discusión que se empezó a dar
respecto de lo que es este blanca en oro
y era esto de bueno cómo es que antes de
ante el ataque de ucrania para el ataque
a ucrania por parte de rusia sale todo
occidente a defender a ucrania y ofrecer
su ayuda bueno qué pasa cuando hay un
país del continente asiático que se ve
en una mala posición nadie sale a
ayudarnos nadie sabe a prestar
cooperación porque todavía seguimos
tienen una mirada
eurocéntrica una mirada eurocéntrica
es ahora ya en la ciudad de bogotá le
pregunto por la sociedad decidí lanka es
un país que en este momento lo vimos muy
unido para pedir el cambio de gobierno
muy unido muy sólido en esas
manifestaciones que llevaron a la
renuncia del presidente y a su posterior
huida hacia las islas maldivas pero en
el pasado esta sociedad no fue tan unida
y este país padeció una guerra civil
precisamente por las diferencias que hay
entre los diferentes grupos étnicos
queda allí y uno de los puntos
importantes para esa recuperación es un
gobierno que represente a todos y que
ayude en conjunto a sacar el país
adelante esta crisis puede volver a
abrir esas heridas del pasado esas
divisiones entre los cingaleses los
tamiles entre las diferentes etnias que
allí
pues santiago en primer lugar aclarar
bueno si blancas de un país en el 70 por
ciento profesa al turismo
y un 12% profesa el hinduismo
además de otras religiones musulmana y
cristiana pues que también son
relativamente importantes pero pero esa
es nunca solamente hasta épocas
recientes esa división se da siempre
fueron sociedades muy unidas han sense
ancestralmente y desde hace más de 800
años fueron fueron comunidades que
convivieron en la isla es el
conocimiento de las izquierdas en los 60
y de los movimientos guerrilleros en esa
época y la consolidación de los brics de
familias del norte en donde se empieza a
pelear por el poder a buscar el poder a
través de esas de esas instancias y pues
obviamente genera unas divisiones muy
fuertes porque la guerrilla también fue
bastante dura bastante
cruenta
en la lucha por sus intereses y
pues lo que lo que yo veo es que
necesitan buscar un gobierno de unidad
un gobierno gobierno en donde el
centroderecha tiene que empezar a jugar
un papel importante y el centroizquierda
y lo que tú ves en televisión de gente
en las bibliotecas del palacio
presidencial y tratando de contener a la
violencia pues es propia del budismo no
es propia de la de los valores que
existen en esas dos religiones el que
dispone el hinduismo
se abrirá en la ciudad de buenos aires-
hablábamos también en la introducción
del programa de sed descontento de esa
sociedad y de la pnc esa completamente
enardecida contra la clase política con
rabia descontento total por las medidas
adoptadas pero no es un escenario ajeno
a la región de américa latina de otros
países alrededor del mundo en donde se
han presentado múltiples manifestaciones
también en contra de los gobiernos de
turno es y dylan acá un punto de partida
de una bola de nieve que pueda empezar a
generar más descontento a nivel social
en otros países no necesariamente
llevará a derrocar los gobiernos pero
pero sí a ver
multitudinarias manifestaciones aquí en
la región lo estamos viendo en argentina
y mucho hay mucho descontento en
términos económicos con el gobierno
panamá lleva varias semanas también con
los ciudadanos en las calles y lo mismo
hemos visto en otros países
bueno me parece que es saludable que en
democracia los los ciudadanos se
manifiesten siempre que sea
pacíficamente
solo que creo particularmente con lo que
ocurre con seri lanka es que al ser un
país que está del otro lado del mundo no
nos llama la atención
porque precisamente nosotros tenemos una
mirada eurocéntrica o sea pasa esto en
francia y están absolutamente todos los
medios abocados a este análisis y sin
embargo pasa esto en serie' lanka y
estamos todos viendo buscando
especialistas a ver dónde dónde queda
blanca qué es lo que pasa digo no me
parece que no es ni más ni menos que la
expresión del descontento de una
sociedad que está cansado de la
corrupción que está cansada de la
desigualdad que está cansada de ver el
nepotismo y sus representantes que una
vez que asumen el poder lo único que
hacen es designar a sus familiares y
evitar los controles y hacerse cada vez
más ricos de
rajapaksa cómo es que alquila en aviones
privados y se van a maldivas y se van a
singapur y más
yo lo que creo es que esto no es ni más
ni menos que situaciones que ya hemos
visto en américa latina de gozoso y
argentinas y situaciones así y las he
visto en el año 2001
y creo que es otra el país si la lejanía
que es una cultura completamente
distinta
pero
sin problemas de división social
problemas económicos y malas decisiones
que toman los gobiernos en soraya en la
ciudad de bogotá quiero que hablemos y
también lo vamos a ir armando este
rompecabezas con la ayuda de sabrina
sobre los protagonistas de esta crisis
que es este clan esta familia rajapaksa
que ha estado en el poder a lo largo de
muchísimos años hay un civil han acá
fueron una familia muy poderosa sobre
todo para lograr la paz en ese país
fueron protagonistas y en cierta forma
artífices de esa paz en sidi la ncaa
pero un momento a otro todo este imperio
toda esta idea de esta dinastía se viene
abajo en cuestión de semanas comenzó con
soraya para que nos dé datos sobre estos
gobernantes sobre los puntos destacados
de su gobierno hasta la caída
pues mira yo yo creo que
más que lograr la paz fue una
pacificación de la la forma como se
venció a la guerrilla también en el
norte de ser la ncaa
obviamente se reconoce el logro de racha
falsa padre de manera que ahora ya pasa
en ese momento de logran someter a la
guerrilla también pero precisamente
naciones unidas en este momento está
investigando y llegando a conclusiones
sobre la violación es terrible son los
derechos humanos que fueron cometidos
tanto por la guerrilla también como por
las fuerzas gubernamentales
y quien merecen poder ser evaluadas y
consideradas por la comunidad
internacional
es efectivamente una familia con mucho
poder
que promovió la corrupción
a la que se acercó china precisamente
por el aislamiento que generó que generó
esa imagen de los raya pacta en la
comunidad internacional
y que finalmente cae pues por lo que se
han plantado aquí es decir el hambre es
ya no da ya lo andrew ua y el país
prácticamente perdió todas las
oportunidades de crecimiento que tuvo
durante la sistemática si sabrina a su
punto de vista sobre esta familia que
gobernó civil blanca durante tantos años
y a lo que veníamos hablando digo solo
que le agregaría es que se trata
realmente de un clan no un clan que está
presente en la política de la década de
1930 que eso con los padres con el padre
de los rajapaksa que hoy que hoy
conocemos que también involucró sus
hermanos bueno ahora tanto gotabhaya
como ma jin de qué bueno vagina fue
presidente después fue primer ministro
gotabhaya fue precisamente quien logró
este proceso que es ahora ya venía
manifestando respecto de los de los
tigres tamiles y ahora también se le
suman otros hermanos roja pacsa es decir
que son cuatro hermanos logia paisaje
que también formaban parte del gabinete
uno como vocero otro como ministro los
hijos de los cuatro hermanos rasca pasa
entonces todo esto realmente genera un
gran hartazgo porque digo son los mismos
personajes las mismas figuritas desde el
año 1930 con injerencia y con
significancia en el escenario político y
lo único que hicieron por lo menos a los
ojos de quienes hoy se están
manifestando es enriquecerse claro
porque después en las medidas las
políticas públicas se han instrumentado
por lo menos en los últimos años no
llega el ciudadano común si un escenario
que tampoco es ajeno américa latina por
lo menos en la historia reciente es un
escenario muy similar sabrina continuó
con usted rápidamente para llegar a las
conclusiones le pregunto qué puede pasar
con estos personajes que huyeron a
maldivas ya están en singapur mandaron
la renuncia al congreso al parlamento a
través de correo electrónico qué va a
pasar con ellos responderán ante cortes
internacionales o esto se queda así en
un gobierno en el exilio o un
simplemente un gobierno que cae y se van
al exilio y el país empieza a escribir
un nuevo capítulo
bueno
jota vaya el presidente acaba de enviar
su carta de renuncia base y va a
anunciar públicamente en algunas horas
lo que hizo fue jugar con su inmunidad
como presidente digo lo que espero al
llegar a un punto seguro a un lugar
seguro para poder enviar su renuncia
bueno otro de los hermanos rajapaksa
también se había ido
creo que va a depender de que digamos de
la visión internacional que se tenga
respecto de esto para ver si se van a
instar algunos de los mecanismos
internacionales
por el momento digo sí y rajapaksa envía
su renuncia está totalmente desvinculado
del gobierno si no vuelve nunca salí
lanka por lo menos dentro de ser y
blanca no lo van a poder jugar
pero creo que en realidad lo más difícil
más allá de la corrupción y todos los
actos que pudieron todo que estado las
tartas cuestionables que pueden haber
hecho los rajapaksa creo que la peor
parte se la lleva a quienes realmente
ahora van a subir el gobierno porque
ahora más allá de lo político y basta
reestructurar toda la parte económica
pues para allá va mi pregunta para la
gran conclusión de el programa se abrirá
se me adelanta un poco pero entonces
comienzo con soraya para darle la
palabra y rotar la conclusión qué va a
pasar con este país que viene ahora cuál
es este primer paso para lograr
esa estabilización no solamente
económica lograr que el país responda a
sus compromisos internacionales sino
para estabilizar a la sociedad de ese
país que está en serias dificultades
económicas cuales es el primer caso para
la conclusión
pues mira yo creo que el primer paso
necesariamente es lograr la negociación
para el rescate y la reestructuración de
la deuda y muy relacionadas con la
pregunta que le dijiste sabrina qué va a
pasar con esta familia necesariamente
una de las demandas del fondo monetario
internacional y de la banca
internacional en general es que se
cumplan las sanciones
que quiere imponer a los responsables de
la violación de derechos humanos pues de
naciones servicios entonces este es uno
de los requisitos luego seguramente
pasará algo con esa más liviana tú hace
referencia a lo que pasa o al referente
en américa latina' ciertamente para mí
lo más importante para américa latina en
relación con lo que está pasando en
blanca es que tenemos que saber negociar
con los países asiáticos y saber
negociar
esas estas obras de infraestructura tan
necesarias en nuestro continente y para
las cuales estamos buscando socios
negociar con tienda no es malo pero
tenemos que saber negociar y tenemos que
tener como referencia lo que está
pasando en esos países pequeños que no
tuvieron esa capacidad china ha
construido recientemente un discurso
sobre el particular diciendo que
efectivamente los países poderosos
negocian tengo con ellos los países que
ha formado a sus diplomáticos etcétera
luego luego nosotros tenemos que tener
cuidado con eso es lo que queremos de
las producciones para que en la
confusión ciones de américa latina
debemos tener porque en américa latina
hay al principal socio comercial de
muchos países de la región es
precisamente china bélgica mina asiático
sabrina su conclusión para el cierre del
programa cuál puede ser ese primer paso
para la estabilización que lo que debe
hacer este país para empezar a salir de
esa crisis
bueno en primer lugar ponerse de acuerdo
en conformar un nuevo gobierno
y tratar de que ese nuevo gobierno
efectivamente
represente una gran cantidad de sectores
como decía seleccionar un momento de
centroizquierda centroderecha
también hay gente que está pidiendo que
no presidente sea de liquidez tamiles
por ejemplo
algo que obviamente es inviable pero a
lo que voy y se empiezan a dar nuevas
demandas respecto de eso creo que lo
fundamental es eso es establecer un
gobierno será de comisión pero será del
coalición entre la oposición pero de
todos modos va a tener que estar una
posición absolutamente seria porque él
es el gobierno digo el país está en una
situación tan dramática que realmente
esto se tiene que tomar con seriedad
para poder reestructurar borrar y dar
resultados rápido al pueblo porque lo
están demandando así a sabrina ya soraya
les agradezco muchísimo un gustazo haber
conversado con ustedes y haber analizado
la política de la crisis que está
viviendo este país asiático muchísimas
gracias por su análisis para la
audiencia de france 24 ustedes puede
seguir dejando sus preguntas y sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales y sigan en sintonía de france
[Música]